[Music]
hey baby we going to be here all day we
going to be here all day baby I like
this kind of party welcome back to the
way back I am Ryan sickler over here
Ryan sickler docomond Ryan sickler on
all your social media today my guest
here Jim Gaffigan everybody thank you
for having me oh thank you for the
obligatory being here Jim you got a
special out on Amazon new special on
Amazon and um on tour always touring
always trying to gain my father's
approval and uh that's what it doing
some yeah no it's like there is
something it's like that 10th special
like why am I doing a 10th special but I
think uh it's fun I like the work I like
the process so growing up let's talk
about you cuz this is all about
Nostalgia and we're in that backseat of
the station wagon here you're one of six
kids yes I'm the youngest I me what is
that like do they bully you did they
pick on you it was uh I was a bit of the
mascot but it was definitely the mascot
that's who said yeah I was definitely uh
you know there was some competition for
food you know cuz parents back then they
were there they were there to kick you
out of the house and tell you to come
back at a certain point I remember my
dad just some nights are just
announcing all right everyone to bed and
we'd be like it's uh 6:00 p.m. and he's
like just go to bed like all right I
guess we're going to bed um but like
even you know like I feel like uh I see
this in uh comedy like I love the
process of writing comedy and I love the
process of you know for acting roles
kind of obsessing on the character and
that go like I remember being a little
kid and I was big into baseball cards MH
loved baseball cards have your own no no
no I don't let's talk after this you got
to have your own Topps card Jim G really
yes but like baseball cards was a big
thing just you know organizing them by
teams by positions I mean obviously
there's some level of autism here like I
would just sit there and be like all
these guys are all from Cuba these guys
are from the domic it was just in
bananas right but I was also like my mom
would just give me a coloring book and
crayons and she would stick me in a room
and I would just color and she would
come back four hours later and I'd still
be coloring so I've always had
that uh obsessive Focus kind of thing
that say the word again where you were
doing what coloring with what crayons
crayons yeah we had this discussion
about crayons crayons yeah crayons I
think it's we you know like supposedly
cuz I said pop growing up did you say
pop no we were everything was soda Kiren
you did yeah I think that's like an Iowa
thing yeah iow oh Iowa see I'm Indiana
but like my wife is from Milwaukee and
she said soda but I think that's unique
in the midwest you know like people in
Buffalo say pop do they and Rochester
New York they say pop and oh so I was
working on something and they were like
if you cuz like there's pop or soda it's
uh shoulder or let down lane or and then
there's a water fountain or bubbler and
all this stuff and then there's Firefly
what do you call them fireflies no uh
lightning bugs lightning bugs yeah and I
took it and I had been away from the
Midwest for so long cuz this this quiz
or whatever would identify where you're
from and uh oh by what you called
different things yeah yeah and they're
like oh you're from
Reno because I think
that I think that what what did you call
uh lightning bugs or uh fireflies I
always call them lightning bugs I think
I can't remember what we call it you're
making me miss it now summer well I
never played Kick the Can I remember
Kick the Can from what was the Spielberg
you you guys played kick the Old Bay
can the Old Bay Seasoning we definitely
and then you had the
buger uh those cookies are amazing yeah
yes they are right the Old Bay stuff you
guys have to settle down with that I'm
big on Old Bay I put it on my eggs all
my oh yeah Seafood tuna fish chicken the
Old Bay thing popcorn well the chips
that's always like you know cuz we have
friends from Maryland they always like
bring the Old Bay and there's like a
crab on everything like let's put a crab
like every house in Maryland's like you
know we this room doesn't have a picture
of a crab it's the you know what yeah
mine's up there right up there bucket of
steam crabs up there yeah it's I still
get them shipped out here we do a couple
crab Feast a year for sure it's it it's
a weird way of life it's almost that
cheesy Forest Gump Shrimp joke but it
really is that with crab in Maryland it
really is and there is nothing better
than like eating crabs and having that
Old Bay I remember being like
17 and cuz we used to go to Maryland my
aunt lived there and we would uh I would
have the old Bas seasoning on my I think
it was old Bas seasoning mhm and on my
lips and it would burn and there would
be a picture of beer and You' drink the
beer and my dad you know so exhausted
from six kid he's like I don't care go
ahead drink and just like getting buzzed
and drinking yeah and eating crabs that
was fun but like crabs is a lot of I had
a lot of material on crabs you did oh
yeah there was a big thing cuz it was a
big cuz the that yellow stuff in the CRA
the mustard I love it yeah that's I
don't like it in the lobster there was
so much more in the lobster just to
tucked in the corners a little bit in
the crab it's like an eye bugger all
that nasty [__] that boil together you
know what I had this was maybe it's been
a minute now with I don't know eight
years or so ago maybe longer but all my
life I had never had this I go to a bar
and they took a draft beer pint glass
and they rimmed it with Old Bay oh and I
was like oh this is the flavor of a
[__] crab Feast right here the beer
in the Old Bay and I there's a little
there's a little Spice in the Old Bay
yeah just a little kick yeah keeps you
thirsty and it probably it keeps you
drinking you would go from Indiana to
Maryland would you drive I think
sometimes we would drive what you what
did you take in all eight people in did
you have a wagon back then yeah there
was definitely well there was there were
cars that were I mean we definitely had
a station wagon we had but we were six
kids so whenever we would go on road
trips there would be two cars
right and so my dad would drive too fast
and lose my mom you know what I mean so
there was always that kind of so if you
were in mom's car she'd be like what the
[__] where is he you know what I mean
and uh you didn't have walkie-talkies or
anything ORV but also I feel like you
know like my dad's like I don't like
slow Walkers I'm a slow Walker you are
yeah and if I get behind one I get
pissed cuz I know how slow I am you know
like I'm kind of a
uh like if we're walking somewhere I'm
like let's let's get there you know what
I mean and but like the like my kids
slow Walkers I'm like we live in New
York City you have to walk fast there's
and I but I do love walking like my wife
doesn't like walking like that is I
enjoy like I'll do a spot at Gotham
Comedy Club and I love walking home some
of it is I close some rings on my watch
yeah I do too I really love the one of
the walks I really like is San Francisco
oh yeah like when you stay down in the
financial district you walk to the
punchline or cobs that's such a great
walk especially in the summer it's a
good one and those Hills and all that
and then you can get I like I get in my
zone on the walk I like it little breath
of fresh air little they got it all
there so what kind of vacations would
you guys take a family of eight that's I
mean that's not easy to pack everybody
up and go somewhere so and also it's not
like you live on the east coast where
you just go to the beach so where you
going Gary Indiana there were big family
trips uh uh that I remember like we uh
when my my grandmother died my mother
inherited some money and they took the
whole family to Europe when I was like
eight or whatever okay and that
transformed my life because I love other
cultures and I love um so that sparked a
real big curiosity and now I love doing
International shows more for you know I
get to visit cities and stuff like that
but um but we would go to
Florida we would drive to like Hilton
Head where else but like we lived on
Lake Michigan so the summer you wouldn't
go somewhere so there is part of me that
and I did a CBS Sunday commentary on
like this whole thing of traveling
during the summer it's doesn't make
sense it's like oh the weather's finally
nice here so we're leaving what is that
all about you know what I mean we just
talked about that like you go to a city
cuz I as a comedian I want to come to
your city when it's nice yes but you
live there and you want to get the [__]
out of there when it's nice yeah yeah
you got to go in the worst times of the
year yeah and so but where else did we
but like we went on a vacation to
Jamaica and did a lot huh yeah we did
some we did some cool trips but not
every year it was like maybe every
couple years
and um but I remember one time I was in
Florida that when I had three older
brothers two older sisters and my oldest
brother that's when I first tried
chewing tobacco he was he gave it to you
yeah it was uh remember what kind Beach
Nut or red man or I think no but I think
it was more snuff oh okay yeah dip it
was dip you know what I mean and uh so
it would be like it must have been
Kodiak cuz I don't think you start with
Copenhagen Hawkins the gateway drug it's
the finger in the
[__] if you're looking to [__] Hawkins
the finger and the [__] skull mint is
neck kissing but [__] Copenhagen is
anal sex it is so
good but eventually I was totally I was
like the guy who had dip you know i' dip
and you know there one beer yeah or
you'd spit in the wrong bot on you're
like God damn it um but yeah so that I
remember that was like the first time I
had a buzz was from dip there was also a
thing where St Patrick's Day they used
to let us go outside and look for a
leprechaun so
weird daytime or night time night time
after have their drink so they're like
they're like you want to go look for a
leprechaun and we're like yeah let's go
do that and so we would go outside and
look for a leprechaun never found one I
did I thought everyone was looking for
leprechauns and not until later on that
I think my parents were just like they
probably getting rid of us to smoke weed
or something I don't know oh so but on
St Patrick's Day When I was a teenager
my dad would let me have a Guinness and
I remember thinking I was like this is
the worst tasting thing in the world and
now I love a Guinness but it was it's
yeah so there is some of those memories
of childhood that are so fascinating
from way back I mean I remember when my
family was introduced to Bagels that was
a big deal me too dude how tell me so it
was I think it was lender
bagel and and my mom brought him home by
the way I remember when we were
introduced to Hummus like that didn't
come till later that was later that was
a different era but it was like but
Bagels I remember just being cuz I used
to eat like for my when I was a little
kid for my 10th birthday my my older
sister
Pam who was kind of like a second mom
she got me a package of hot dogs for my
birthday and a sixpack of Dr Pepper I
mean that's pretty weird right so and
and it was they were great gifts they
were great gifts cuz it was you know now
it's so easy to get soda but back then
it was you know and of course we called
it pop but she you know it was like got
me my own sixpack of Dr Pepper remember
and I loved popcorn I I got my own air
like it was very modern an air popcorn
maker mhm like you didn't even need oil
it was just air air hot air just air and
and and the air would get so hot that
you could melt butter yeah and then on
top of it over top and so uh just weird
stuff of childood bagel that was a big
deal right yeah but Baltimore Jewish
Community there there must have been
Bagels right it was yeah but we were
Italians so it was all bread bread bread
it wasn't bagel and then I will go to a
friend's house lender's Bagels I'll
never forget they had egg bagels it was
my first Inu and they had them in the
freezer oh wow and he took it out of the
freezer and he toasted one and I was
like what the [__] is this and I've been
hooked ever since oh yeah is there
anything from childhood you to this day
will still a meal or a anything that
you'll indulge in you know during the
pandemic I had my two younger Sons cuz
my wife is pretty healthy and uh but I
had my two younger Sons try all this
stuff that I used to eat like baloney
was a big part of my childhood like
eating baloney going through eras where
it was like baloney and ketchup and then
it was like balone and mustard and then
balone and Mayo it was like but my kids
during the pandemic they had never had
balone so I was like all right we're
going to get some baloney and you're
going to try baloney and they were like
this is amazing and then there was um my
dad used to eat mush what is that one it
was kind of like cornmeal mush and then
we also would have Welsh Welsh rare rare
bit have you ever heard of that I've
heard of it but I have no idea and
that's just essentially melted cheese on
toast oh is that all that is and but
it's very Tangy it's like a cheddy Tang
but brw were a big thing during the
summer growing up that was and I
remember cuz the name sounded so
horrible we're having broadw worst oh
and then I was like oh this is good but
I used to just I would come home from
school and I would either eat a sleeve
of crackers mhm or I would just grab
like four pieces of Wonderbread and I
would go downstairs and I would eat one
Wonderbread on fold it into like a cube
you know what I used to do with
Wonderbread i' take I'd heat it in the
microwave for like 15 seconds get it all
soft and warm and I would take the crust
off and I would wad it up into a ball
and I put it in my mouth like it was
chewing the back up that's what I used
to do instead of snuff and stuff and
keep that bread in there till it got
slobbery and soft and then I'd eat it
yeah you the amazing thing I tried to do
material about Wonderbread because you
know it went out of business because
because but it was like it's a wonder
anyone believed it was bread cuz
it's because it never molds nothing it's
like the McDonald's of bre it's you put
it in the toaster and it catches on fire
Bread's not supposed to catch on
fire you
know your own family vacations what do
you do have you ever have you ever had
one that you were like [__] yeah nailed
it well because of standup I've been
able to take my kids amazing places and
I've BR with you on some gigs and things
and I you know we did a 30 day bus tour
with five kids on a bus Which my wife
was like we're never doing that again
but so like they've been amazing places
I think the greatest the biggest
surprise is how they don't remember any
of
it so like none of it parents are like
we're going to take our daughter to
Disney World I'm like unless she's 13
yeah 13 don't bother
don't bother cuz and my dog my my wife
had
never she never I don't think I'm sure
she went maybe once but like it was
something it was like just she's one of
nine kids it was just kind of out of the
price range for her family so whenever I
would shoot something in LA or she would
be like we're taking the kids to
Disneyland and I'm like we've gone like
10 times in the past year and she's like
but I never got to go as a kid
so and then Orlando is a big uh you know
the amusement park thing and I hate it I
love it and hate it because it is you
know as a parent there's nothing you
enjoy more than seeing your children
happy but you're also like voluntarily
putting yourself in a hellish situation
also especially being you and your
stature and your job how do you [__]
well I'm also too pale for
outdoors I'm just not design or Orlando
in July it's like what here's what I do
love about Disney World is
that you can focus completely on your CH
your children because there's no
distractions so it's either it's parents
with their little kids
exhausted then there's maybe the
teenagers but then there's grandparents
or like you know uh fat people in their
50s there's no one attractive so like
you're not distracted by anything you
can be floating by at the beach you you
can be the best dad ever cuz there's
nothing to distract you you can just
be uh their suffering CU that's what
happens essentially you suffer and then
you have to carry them home because
they're so tired and then they don't
remember any of it so Kirsten do you
have any questions you want to ask I do
uh my first question is as a child of
six what kind of games and stuff did you
and your siblings make up and play when
you were younger oh uh well a big thing
in my family is the biggest insult would
be among my siblings would be to call
another
sibling a different sibling okay so it
would be like okay
Pam okay Mitch and then because the
everyone and it obviously shifted like
if someone was like problematic or if
somebody was uh uh known as selfish if
someone did some selfish behavior you
would call them by that recently
described selfish person um if you were
kind of uh uh you know my oldest sister
was kind of aloof she was like the
firstborn was like I can't believe I'm
even in this family so if anyone was
aloof or the equivalent of snobby it was
like okay you're like Kathy you know
what I mean but of course my sister
Kathy's nothing like that but um to kids
that's what it insult it's so beautiful
yeah it's a double insult did your
siblings ever try to mess with your
baseball cards oh yeah but it was one of
those things where I think they were
just not interested it was it was a you
something that I cared about that I
don't think they really cared about but
that being said being the youngest of uh
six kids and the youngest of four
boys I did not feel safe I didn't do you
know what I mean yeah I you know the
mascot you know what I mean it was just
I had to I used to do an impression of
my dad and that would kind of gain their
favor i' be like all right I might go
again Jesus
Christ Ryan sickler how many podcasts
can you have
sickler doesn't sound Italian to me it's
not um I have one from Martin over here
what's your relationship with Hot
Pockets like
today uh we're
divorced dude that was my college food
forever Lean Pockets I went with the
lean I save 10 20 someone's watching
their
fig and for dessert did you have a diet
Twinkie um uh yeah no the Hot Pocket
thing it's interesting because I you
know obviously that was in my first
special but there was years that I would
do it because people would it was a
great kind of like Encore bit or it just
left the crowd really happy or there
people would be like I want to hear the
hot pocket but and it kept
expanding but I you know I would say
maybe 10 years since I've been do uh
since I've done it so there is
occasionally
it's still pointed out you know like I
did this show Full Circle where when we
first meet my character I'm eating a
7-Eleven burrito and I said to the
director I was like you know I'm kind of
known for the hot pocket do we really
want me to be eating something that
could look like a Hot Pocket and he
looked at me like you're crazy you know
no one cares and I'm like all right all
right all right and so then but of
course then I read a review it's like
Jim gaffan opens the scene where he's
eating a Hot Pocket you know what I mean
so it's like some some of it is in my
imagination and some of it is if you
know but I think if I die right now I I
would be less
likely I would still be known as The Hot
Pocket guy but it's it's less than it
used to be um I want to know one what
about for you is a give me a dad fail
like where you're like man and I dropped
a ball on this one oh I think when iPads
really started happening I remember
turning to my brother-in-law and I was
like these iPads these apps are key
they're great cuz they're educational so
like I totally exposed my kids to
screens immediately not realizing the
house I mean obviously it's so apparent
how stupid it is right for everyone but
I was the guy like these screens are
great
Jim Gavin's Pro tablet over here yeah so
worst dad in the world we're going to
wrap it up right here thank you very
much for doing this than so much um
again one more time with your plugs
anything you'd like please uh check out
the new Amazon special uh it's called
Dark pale I also have uh a bunch of
specials on Netflix and a bunch on uh
Amazon Prime so always onour
always on tour and uh always writing
right just trying to get people to like
me you're the man thank you so much as
always Ryan sikler come see me on tour
we'll talk to you all next
[Music]
week
I